[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci la place Rouge éta
VI devant moi marcher
Nathalie il avait un joli nom mon
guide
Nathalie la place Rouge était blanche la
neige faisait un tapis et je suivais par
ce froid
dimanche Nathalie
elle parlait en phrase sobre de la
Révolution
d'Octobre je pensais déjà
qu'après le tombeau de Lénine on irait
au café poukine
boire boire un
chocolat la place Rouge était vide je
lui pris son bras elle a souri il avait
des cheveux blancs non guide
[Musique]
Natalie Natalie
dans sa chambre à
l'université une bande d'étudiants
l'attendait
impatiemment on a ri on a beaucoup
parler il voulait tout
savoir it
traduisait
Moscou les plaines d'Ukraine et les
Champs Élysées on a tout mélangé dans la
chanté et puis
ilouch la Champagne de à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
danser
et quand la chambre fut
vide tous les amis étaient partis je
suis resté seul avec mon
guide
Nathalie et plus question de phrases
sobre ni de révolution d'Octobre on n
était plus là
adieu le tombeau de Lénine le chocolat
de chez pou qui ne
sait c'était loin
déjà que la vie me semble vide mais je
sais qu'un jour à Paris c'est moi qui
lui servirai te
guide
[Musique]
Nathalie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nataliie